[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bruce au notre petit
nuage et bien chargé ce soir oh oui on a
eu bien du mal à arriver
nous sommes noyés dans les lettres le
tout sous le poids que tu ferais bien
d'aller distribuer leur courrier à
nicolas et pimprenelle nounours tu
encore patron et vous pendant ce temps
là vous pourrez dire le vôtre tenu
encore une m merci facteur mais ne soyez
pas trop long service rapide patron
houleux lors ce que celle où on les
jeunes hommes propos de monsieur le
marchand de sable
quelles tendances faisons le factor
bonjour moi tes joues pas c'est moi le
facteur du sel je peins de courrier pour
vous
ce dogme chaptelat ce cube loup paul
ince et toutes les lettres pour nous
le bouddhisme
on me dit dans une lettre au ca non tu
t'es tu m'achètes patronne l on veut du
sétois lire plus loin de vous dites de
bâle
voyons voir mon frère nounours c'est
pour moi ou c'est une belle note
je t'aime beaucoup que c'est gentil mais
parfois tu triches ce n'est pas bon par
exemple voyons une eau à oui elle était
que rien justement l'heure nicolas et
pimprenelle je suis très sage et veut
chaque soin me coucher en même temps que
vous mais je suis très mécontent quand
vous faites des bêtises à mon gros du
lourd chéri votre petit jean christophe
où le charme au tofu a fallu répondre à
l'annoncé wii qui vous aidera et ce
paquet nous voyons
[Musique]
mouvaux du mieux qu est ce qui est écrit
je m'appelle parti j'ai 8 ans et j'en
vois un petit pot de miel nounours car
je sais qu'ils l'aiment bien gros bisous
markine
merci peut-être martin schulz diatta tos
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que tu fais un ours je
regarde c'est tout le propos du bac et à
vie la cour marware oui pas 3g / -
d'express c'est un recommandé pour moi
vraiment tout de suite gros gourmand
mais couche d'abord nicolas et
pimprenelle et emprunt c'est très fort
de ma part le marchand de sable odorants
monsieur dame on y va
[Musique]
e
bonne nuit les petits la un gros baiser
de la part de mon patron justin la ligne
heures de nuit connu monsieur facteurs
bus de nuit
monsieur des nuits nicolas n'est pas
banal tort bien
oui
au niveau
[Musique]
vos nuits nicolas bonne nuit pimprenelle
bonne nuit tous les enfants et un grand
merci à tous ceux qui nous envoient de
si jolies lettres avec de beaux dessins
des photos qui nous font très plaisir
oh oui merci me reçut en road nounours
dans la nuit faute de pour eux
[Musique]